Lucas black knows how to make an exit
and so does NCIS New Orleans heads-up
major spoilers ahead during the sixth
episode of season six called Matthew 5:9
Black's character special agent
Christopher LaSalle died after
sustaining gunshot wounds to his arm and
stomach while on a mission to avenge the
death of his brother it's not easy to
say goodbye to a key character after six
seasons but it's comforting to know that
black reportedly didn't apart from NCIS
New Orleans on a whim or because of any
behind-the-scenes drama no one knew
about instead black exited the
procedural for a very important reason
to spend more time with family in a
video uploaded to NCIS New Orleans
YouTube channel black who's married with
three children explained his decision to
part ways of the CBS series he admitted
that while the show has been quote so
good to him over the years the schedule
wasn't always easy there's a lot of
priorities in my life that get
sacrificed for me to be here but it's
time for me to focus on those priorities
it may be tough for fans to accept a
beloved star has other priorities but
nothing but love and support has
surrounded Black's dramatic exit from
the show according to TV insider the
NCIS New Orleans showrunner said in a
statement we had an amazing run with
Lucas black and he has been such an
important part of our NCIS New Orleans
team we are sad to see him go but happy
he will have more time to spend with his
family high-profile stars might
sometimes use family as a fake excuse to
exit in an wanted situation the blacks
co-workers seemed convinced that his
reasons are genuine CCH pounder who
plays medical examiner Loretta Wade said
in a video released by the show that
black wasn't all that concern with the
idea of being a Hollywood star the most
important thing
to be a family man and I think he's just
that over all the other choices black
who according to CBS earned his first
film role when he was 11 has mainly
worked on NCIS over the last six years
Newsweek previously speculated that
black might be leaving the show to free
up time for other on-screen ventures
like future installments of The Fast and
the Furious franchise in which he plays
tokyo-based American street racer Shawn
Boswell black last appeared in 2015's
Furious 7 and was also in 2006's The
Fast and the Furious Tokyo Drift rumors
of his casting and fast in the Furious 9
have swirled for several years but black
was also expected to appear in the
eighth movie in the franchise and didn't
while it's not clear yet whether black
will appear in Fast and Furious 9 it's
also unknown whether any movie casting
would have taken him away from NCIS New
Orleans as for what's mixed for the
actor black didn't offer any hints about
future movie roles in his own video
posted to Twitter after the death of
LaSalle instead he chose to focus on
expressing gratitude for fans for all
their love and support you were there to
celebrate the victories and to pick me
up when I needed it and I appreciate
that the actor also indicated he would
miss playing LaSalle and remains
incredibly thankful for the time he
spent on NCIS New Orleans he went on to
say that he quote learned a lot about
what the first responders do and that he
supports and respects the military
chapters and what a great journey it was
thank you guys so much may God bless you
so far much of NCIS New Orleans season
six has been about LaSalle search for
his missing brother whom he then
discovers is dead and his team's
attempts to help him in his quest it's
not clear where that plot will go after
LaSalle's death and a preview of the
next episode of the show excitingly
titled boom-boom-boom-boom
only teases a new storyline involving
bombs in the city
however NCIS New Orleans star in a car
zot again who plays Special Agent Hannah
Cory promised that LaSalle's character
would have a major effect on the show
LaSalle's character was such a big
important character
show it does have a big impact on the
team in terms of not just the
relationships but personal stories Starr
Scott Bakula who portrays Supervisory
Special Agent Dwayne King pride also
revealed that LaSalle's death means
change for NCIS New Orleans we're off on
a big dramatic change in our in our
world here for season six while the NCIS
franchise is still going strong ratings
for NCIS New Orleans have sadly been
declining
according to TV by the numbers though
it's likely upsetting for fans of the
actor LaSalle zegs it just might give
the show a shot in the arm for fresh
plot lines for the rest of the season
and beyond check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about your favorite TV shows are
coming soon subscribe to our YouTube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]